stellen sie sich vor
nach einem selber am glück gibt es ein
breites blackout es funktioniert kein
händen jetzt mehr
die supermärkte werden ausgeraubt sie
hören schüsse auf den straßen herrscht
das recht des stärkeren
ein zweites szenario terroristen mit
kampferfahrung aus krisengebieten
bewaffnet mit maschinengewehren
panzerfäusten und granatwerfern bedrohen
das leben der österreicherinnen sollen
möglichst viele tote und schwerverletzte
produziert werden die kritische
infrastruktur staudämme flughäfen und
der gleiche musik betont sie die haben
jetzt sicher das österreichische
bundesheer schützt sind derartige
situationen muss sie leider enttäuschen
aufgrund der drastischen sparmaßnahmen
der letzten 30 jahren können wir das
nicht mehr ausreichend gewährleistet
im vorliegenden bericht erfahren sie
mehr details was sind die bedrohungen
was braucht es um sie zu schützen welche
investitionen sind notwendig und wie
schaut ein gangbarer weg in das jahr 20
30 aus damit tierschutz und ihre
sicherheit wieder durch das
österreichische bundesheer gewährleistet
ist